the US Marine Corps has begun  operational testing of the notoriously  over-budget f-35b  Joint Strike Fighter hoping to have the  stealth jet ready for combat duty in  July but this doesn't mean that when  July hits the Marines will fire up the  engines and fly into a combat zone if  deemed combat ready the Marines are  effectively approving its basic  functionality according to the Pentagon  current limitations include how many  weapons the f-35 can carry its night  flying capabilities and its ability to  spot targets among the more troubling  problems is a lack of infrared pointer  capability to distinguish friendly from  hostile forces it's actually not unusual  for a new combat ready vehicle to stay  out of the action take for example the  f-22 the similarly expensive fighter was  declared combat ready in 2005 but it  wasn't until September of 2014  nine years later that an f-22 actually  flew in Syria on its first combat  mission